pearl's like hold on baby everybody just
calm down son just calm down we black oh
we need to stick together trust me son
hollywood is expecting us to fail baby
let's just calm down go to africa for a
few years everything cools off oh
africa dave who want to go to africa
africans don't even want to go to africa
and they live there
hey man look this is the [ __ ] right
here man for real if anybody want to say
something man for me he gonna be in rush
hour fo yeah it's called uh
oh
hey man and i wish i were full man
you know because you know i i have um
you know i invested so much you know
money into small businesses and you know
i think people you know they really need
to just you know take me
pers you know
take me for real because you know i'm
not playing hold on you
housewife
you ain't got the answers man you ain't
got the how where is your clothing line
we don't even know
clothing line
[Laughter]
ain't the rock johnson and kevin kevin
hart splitting the bill okay yeah let's
do this all right
listen here's the problem hey what the
problem is i'm gonna be straight on
twitch the problem is duane i'm not
splitting the check with you because i
only ordered buffalo wings that's all i
had that's all i could fit in my body
duane look at my body my body looks like
a pedigram
i can't eat all the food that you ate
you ordered the whole restaurant so i
think you should pay for the whole bill
uh come on jabroni the wrong sentence
you know it's really serious that you
pay kevin you know why you say that
you're balling you're supposed to be the
best the number one comedian in the
world so you know you can cover it this
time and i've got the next one at the
applebee
kat williams i used to do this thing on
tinychat on twitter where i would go
into the chat room and not have a
picture and i would just be different
celebrities and the the people's
favorite one was cat williams and one
day cat williams actually came into the
room and i knew it was him because he
had pictures of his babies that were not
online i knew it was him
and he got mad at me too he was like do
you know my babies you ignorant son of a
[ __ ] children you know my babies
you don't serve
sir here's the thing sir first what you
need to do is get somebody that you
actually sound like cause you don't
sound nothing like me bobo that's what
he said
and the people in the room i had you
know got friends and fans they were like
no that ain't cat william j sound more
like cat williams than you do and i was
like yo bruh that's the actual dude
because i can hear it but they were like
nah we got your back jay get that fake
cat out of here i was like y'all just
this the real cat williams had a great
set charlie calls me to the green room
he goes hey yo man
listen man yo man that was a great [ __ ]
man would you do that cam around the dip
[ __ ] stuff yo shane i was on my back
laughing like a turtle that's what i did
man
it was gilbert godfrey yeah i'm mounting
jeffrey
that dude
gilbert that was my first night i used
to watch disney all the time and i would
pick up the impression so i would go
around like do you really think you know
what you're saying
everybody was your fault everybody would
you ever consider running for president
i mean i mean okay okay okay
all right listen listen listen listen
listen
at this point anybody could be the
president listen i don't care
listen
i don't
i don't care flavor flav runs i vote for
him if he wins and make honey boo boo
the vice president i don't care
but i've been doing shaq for so long i
can tell you exactly what he's thinking
right now
all my friends were saying mean things
hurt my feelings
shack a big strong man outside
what's off inside
shaq hate bullets
everyone is calling shack dumb
but shaq not dumb
i have a doctorate
charles is a dumb one
charles probably think dr redd is a girl
doctor
shaka boy doctor
here we go
i'm just just getting when i do the
whole face sometimes it makes me really
laugh
he really looks like he knows a secret
that's about to happen to everybody yeah
nobody knows but me yeah
you know um
you know so i work for qvc now i guess
the you know i guess the rona hit
everybody pretty hard you know
and uh you know i just want you to know
that you know um
actually i just signed up for qbc
qvc sorry no b
unless it's her you know
i just signed up for qvc to just you
know be seen and you know tell people
that y'all owe me money because i've
influenced every poster sir
jay-z
she uh
[Applause]
denzel washington all right okay okay
that's what it is ryan you're old man
uh kevin hart hey listen first of all
the problem
listen can't just do that jimmy what's
the problem man
it's taken over
[Music]
how would you
accept
an oscar well you know with first i
would say to these people
if i just heard them
you know what
i gotta say i gotta say this why
why did it take so long that's my
question i should have been had me an
oscar
you've seen me y'all seen
you
you seen me do dream girl oh yes yes
yes four years yes yes yes
yeah uh pete davidson uh yeah bro
[Applause]
snoop dogg hey yo one two three into the
five
uh uh president obama uh okay now i i i
i understand uh that i'm appreciated in
hawaii that's why i go there
because i'm still working on it you know
i still working i'm still working on it
please don't tell me you know i come on
so that means there's more that means
yes
for me to do and it's more for me you
know if i take a paper and i start
reading it here when skip starts talking
because you know most of the time when
skip starts talking all the thing i hear
is bulls you know what i'm saying
because skip doesn't know what he's
talking about most of the time and i'm
just like i know exactly what's going
down lebron has got to get it done
there is no way
he's got to get it done
two to two there's time right now he's
got to get it done and then chris boyce
comes back chris boss looks just like a
catfish
he looks just like a catfish
there's no way chris bosh hey look i see
personally
personally personally
i think it'll throw off he's going to
throw off
the rhythm personally personally you
didn't say that you didn't say that yeah
i'm saying
uh uh uh jamie foxx hey hey what's up
baby how's everybody feeling
uh uh how about uh the rock
you know what jabroni the rock says this
if you're gonna read my name call me
dwayne murphy
now hold on jabroni what the rock does
is the rock is gonna eat everything here
so there's gonna be nothing left for
anybody else isn't that right barack
well i believe uh i should be able to
get at least a piece of chicken all
right i should be able to get a piece of
chicken and uh you know maybe maybe a
steak and
also maybe a dessert because i've had a
stressful time for the last
decade so you know
it's just uh you know i went from jet
black to cisco baby that was uh that's
what happened with my hair right there
i said hey boy i said
hold on there player hold on there boy
cause you know steve harvey be looking
like this here he be looking like this
here
listen listen boy listen you know good
and hell well you know good and hell
well i supposed to be on the diet ain't
nothing left but fried chicken i can't
eat this i need me a healthy
oh plate god